robin's actually going content he called
me he asked me to ask him to call me
back next day but he didn't i don't know
a month
600 000 plays from your album that you
released three years two three years ago
then i was like and they were like wow
that's around
five six thousand dollars for just
nothing i'm like what
i was kidding what so who who the hell
has
my music money time to uh let everybody
know about this guy
so when i got in touch obviously i
wasn't aware of what happened that day
um i found out the next morning but
we'll get into this
to bring out another sin it's it's it's
haram
it's haram they could do the most evil
like stuff
in private to bring that out to public
it is haram
if you guys don't like each other yes
don't back by each other don't stand
each other you know why
because on the day of judgement you're
going to end up giving your good deeds
to the one that you don't like
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
the website is in the description link
below you can also use a discount code
salam 10 for 10 of their products
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are aware inshallah before
i start winning praise allah subhanahu
wa tara the most must for the most trust
or praise his glory and gratitude belong
to him we ask allah subhanahu wa
to make us sincere and amongst those who
worship him and worship him and him
alone
before doing this video i consulted with
my teachers uh
one of them picked up the phone the
other one didn't and i told him look
this is the reason why i want to do it
reconciliation in the context it doesn't
mean that you guys become buddies etc
but i wanted to share you guys with you
guys inshallah my take on the matter
um my take is not important i'm not here
to be a savior i'm not here to come and
be superman yeah so i'm not trying to be
superman here and come and say save the
day but genuinely when i'm seeing the
fitnah taking place
absolute slander from both sides the
followers from both sides
attacking each other i thought i would
do this video and brothers and sisters
wallahi
i asked you guys to feel lost supano
okay to the best of your ability ramadan
is around the corner we're like
literally above
20 something days away here the prophet
the sabbath would prepare to ramadan six
months in advance yeah
to prepare for a fight it's the it's a
month subhanallah that is there
to revive our connection with allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala yeah
and allah put this legislation in place
for your salah from your salah
from your salah to another salah from
jamaat to juma from umrah to umrah from
hashtag from ramadan to ramadan
from the hijab these are things allah
has put in place for us to have that
reconnection with allah
however the reason why i wanted to do
this video brothers and sisters is
because
it's sad to see anywhere seeing you know
muslims attacking each other it's not
needed okay we've got
external enemies throwing arrows from
left right center we don't need to fight
each other okay
um so now there's accusations that's
been made yeah
and brother adam saleh is
um and brother robin is actually going
contact me called me
he asked me to ask him to call me back
next day but he didn't i don't know why
um so the thing is brothers and sisters
yeah is that i have both their contact
numbers i can get in contact with them
but the
matter is taken to the public sphere so
i'm talking to you guys and in return
shall i be talking to them as well
and we can squash this inshallah firstly
ramadan is around the corner yeah that's
one visa for god's sake okay
now secondly brothers and sisters
brother adam is accusing
brother naz from stealing certain funds
from the music that he made from spotify
or something like that yeah which
amounts are about a hundred thousand
pounds which i found for the troops um
podcast
in return what's happened this obviously
brother naz is
he doesn't he's not happy with
accusations he's saying that
that didn't happen or along those lines
and he's saying that his family are
getting hate comments his children are
being bullied at school etc
you bought that with this uh money of
adam's side
blah blah and then he's come out and
made a series of allegations i watched
nearly all of it
you know um to the best of my ability
just wanted to hear where he's coming
from
and he comes with some very very
disturbing stuff in the context where
in the and i just want to touch on this
he's accusing for example
uh brother adam all kinds of stuff that
i'm not gonna mention i'm not gonna
reiterate here
um all kinds of stuff here and now from
the sharia perspective this is a book
from half aussie the summary of cemetery
students here
if you read here how severe the
accusation for example for one to accuse
another of theft
and one accusing the other or for
example rape or
uh fraud or whatever it may be okay
these are serious damn accusations
prophets yeah
okay you are you guys are brothers and
we love you for the sake of allah
and there was a time where we um
disliked you for the sake of allah not
you personally because you've not done
nothing
personal to me brother nazar brother
adam you know i never
had a personal issue with you guys till
this date i don't that's why for example
when
brother adam opened up by me of the
discussion i was open i had no grudge i
had nothing inside me because it was
nothing personal
i don't want to have anything personal
about me if i do have something personal
i really need to question myself and my
intentions
why do i have something personal against
him and that is my shortcoming not other
persons
so it was never about my individual but
it was about the deen it was about the
deen and
for example the youth being led astray
et cetera as prophet naz you you know
you care about your childhood
right this is your father you care about
his well-being but
also you need to bear in mind that you
have a child imagine there's certain
group of people who are misleading
um your your son it would hurt you
brothers both of you i'm speaking to
both of you yeah
you guys need to squash this well the
reason you need to squash this is look
allah
certain events take place would you ever
thought that a time will come where
when i had the issue with both you guys
in the context because of the demand i
was advising and you guys
you know you didn't like it look where
we are today that subhan allah
um i used to work with the with a
brother that we was together
and you two to a given now i don't i
love them for the sake i have nothing
personal against him i speak to him
every now and then but we have a
disagreement with
brother imran i don't really work with
him as much and now you two aren't
working this is
this is how allah subhanahu wa tala's
wisdom works yeah you
you don't know where you're going to be
yeah today's enemies will be tomorrow's
best friend
tomorrow today's best friend will be
tomorrow next day's enemies
so don't just have anger towards each
other and just let everything out okay
as today you guys had a bit of a dispute
and you are now
talking about each other's private
matters brothers imagine well like this
every mind imagine that you
came imagine on the day of judgement
brothers and sisters
how we're going to be imagine yeah
imagine how we're going to be
if you guys don't like each other yes
don't back by each other don't stand
each other you know why because on the
day of judgement you're going to end up
giving your good deeds to the one that
you don't like
if you don't like it people die dislike
and they really want my blood i abstain
from
talking ill of them you know why because
i don't want to go on the day of
judgment and someone that i hate so much
and i'm gonna end up giving my goodness
to the one i don't like
i would rather be quiet hold my mouth
because holding my mouth means that i'm
not going to be giving him something
that's going to benefit from me
i don't want to benefit from here too
from the sharia perspective
to allah and his messenger like the
companion who came to the prophet peace
before him said and he said i saw
my wife committing zinna
this this can you imagine coming to the
message of allah and you're opening your
heart your brain and saying i caught my
wife coming in with another man
yeah the the messenger of allah he could
have said you know what that's deep
what the hell but he works based on what
allah's legislation
you bring us evidence we take it other
than that we do not step out that realm
so much so you know what he said to the
man he said you
we're gonna have to lash you yes lush
for what slander the reason i'm saying
this in the sight of allah both of your
statements are not valid
in the context brother adam accusing
brother naz of stealing
is not valid let me tell you why and
brother
uh nas accusing brother adam of like
very very disturbing
stuff whatever it is in the sharia both
for you guys
could potentially if he was even on the
islamic rule you guys would be in big
trouble
big trouble brothers yeah and i'm seeing
this because i love both of you guys
here
so you need to understand that it is
very important for you guys
to stop this stop it because you do not
know what's gonna happen reconciliation
could happen
it's not good okay bring in the personal
stuff and not only that one lie it's a
sin
brothers both for you guys yeah i'm
speaking to you to bring out another
sin it's it's it's haram it's haram what
life they could do the most
evil like stuff in private to bring that
out to public
it is haram this is wrong that is the
reason why when we first used to
advise brother adam and yourself prophet
naz you know
we was attacked oh don't judge them et
cetera and we were saying look
we're talking about matters that are
public since we're not going to private
if i went and recorded brother adam or
knew something about him and brought it
it's haram on me i could never do that
but the things we were talking about is
the matters that were in the public
when it comes to the matter of private
it is forbidden
it is forbidden so much so that the
process of selling said that
all like that
that all of the mankind will be adam son
of other muslims
will be forgiven except those who go and
ex
spread their own sins their own sins
won't be forgiven
brothers and sisters what about the ones
who are know the sins and the secrets of
other others which is an amana
it's actually in a manner you know i'm
trying to say that is the honor of
another belief and i'm talking to both
of you guys i'm not taking nobody's side
so for you guys that are listening here
you might be on brother
neither side or brother adam's whatever
it may be you guys are on one side and
that's your muslim
you're muslims you both are muslims
ramadan is around the corner please for
the sake of allah i believe both parties
that's my advice you can take or not
just take the videos down yeah the
accusation towards the money is being
stolen
the accusation of something else
whatever etc and it's sad because what
it is sometimes
you know it seems if we're using certain
cards
that we have and we're using it and
what's sad is like if certain things
have happened
we shouldn't use that based on okay
you've wronged me and i'm gonna now use
this
if somebody's being wrong that wrong has
to be addressed yeah
if person a is being wronged by person b
person a's
mat has to be addressed there and then
or whatever it may be you shouldn't that
shouldn't be used as like okay i'm gonna
you know i'm not gonna talk about this
but now i'm to talk about because you
violated me or you
that's not fair as well okay so i don't
want to get into specifics
i'm not going to go out anybody i'm not
on nobody's side yeah you both are my
brothers i love you both for the sake of
allah even though that's what's happened
i've forgotten about aki do you know
what i'm trying to say brothers so all
i'm asking for you guys is that
ramadan is round the corner and
reconciliation is very important the
process of sallam
has um mentioned this abu dhabi reported
the messenger of allah peace and
blessings
allah be upon him shall i not tell you
of what is better in decree
then extra fasting yeah uh
prayer and charity these are major
things
salah zakyah charity yeah
fasting yeah they said of course the
prophet said reconciliation between
people very the corrupted relation
between people is the razor
yeah isn't this yes yeah so that's the
reason why i see upon myself
that um to ask you brothers for the sake
of allah subhanahu wa ramadan around the
corner
you do not know what situation's going
to change and how you guys are going to
be best friends after
even if you're not leave at that do not
accuse one another and like i said
before under the sharia
under the sharia yeah it's both for your
famous brothers and sisters
is invalid accusing stealing
he did this he did that etcetera and
talking about stuff it's it's
well like brothers and sisters we need
to feel all so paranoid and i'm asking
you guys
please inshallah leave it at that so you
don't want to talk to each other don't
talk to them block each other no problem
this
stuff gives you the right you know broke
each other even though the process of
said that you know believers should not
go three days without talking to each
other
um they should talk to each other
however look if you guys don't want to
give
leave it yeah and for those who are
trolling and loving this one
you guys got disease in your heart
ramadan is there to purify you
for those who are going back and forth
et cetera and bullying nazis
children or vice versa this is haram
this wrong this is wrong
this is wrong even if it is true that uh
nazi took money from him and thinking
about you have no right to go and bully
his kids
you have no right and vice versa uh
because nat said something and now
you're gonna go and start bullying adam
or his family members it's haram
this is violating the rights of other
believers one is violating the right of
the other one another one's one is the
other one
and then now you've got people
underneath violating each other's family
members
brothers please for the sake of allah
i'm asking you guys again
ramadan is around the corner please
let's leave this i would personally say
take the videos down
leave it at that if it's a legal issue
somebody's
right if somebody's right has been
violated whoever it may be
you have a right to go to the
authorities and you should go to the
authorities
and deal with it get solicitors or
whatever it may be you can do that
nobody can stop you but to go and
subhanallah go down this route where you
guys are doing this while i it's not
nice you're exposing each other since
he's going to come out and say oh you
know um
something like what he was doing beating
up his girlfriend wife whatever this is
private matters
these are private matters man well like
these are private matters you do not
bring things
to the open like this brothers and
sisters we ask allah to protect us
that's my take on the matter
and i genuinely ask you brothers for the
sake of allah
to drop it
you